during the samsung event that revealed
the galaxy note 10 there was a surprise
that no one was really expecting
and honestly it's probably the most
exciting announcement for me personally
and that's the galaxy book s if you've
been following the channel you've heard
of us talking about mobile chips getting
big improvements year over year
while intel's been lagging behind and
how apple is paving the way
to switch to their own cpus and macbooks
well
now it's officially here but samsung
beat them to the market with an arm chip
designed for a full os instead of just
being repurposed
and to be honest it could give a lot of
thin laptops including macbook airs
a run for their money before we dive
into performance and special features
along with one big disappointment let's
talk about the exterior
the laptop has a very simple design
which is a good thing but it also has a
curve by the hinge which i think is a
nice addition
the top and bottom look to be aluminum
but i'm uncertain about the palm rest
the keyboard is a low profile chiclet
design and we also have a fingerprint
scanner and a large trackpad
at the top we have a 720p webcam but
unfortunately no windows slow facial
recognition
overall it is slightly thinner and
smaller than the macbook air
and weighs just 2.1 pounds compared to
2.75 pounds
that may not sound like a big difference
on paper but if you remember the 12-inch
retina macbook which was two pounds
that felt much lighter than the macbook
air but of course that only had one port
and really poor performance with thermal
throttling
the galaxy book s will be much faster
with a larger display and just slightly
heavier
on the sides we thankfully still have a
headphone jack unlike the note 10
and two usb type c ports which seem to
be usb
3.1 gen 2 for up to 1 250 megabytes per
second bandwidth
and they can also support two 4k
displays on the bottom we have a nano
sim and micro sd card combo slot
with support for up to one terabyte sd
cards we've had lte connected devices
like ipads and smart watches for years
so i've always wondered why laptops have
been left out but recently we're
starting to see this push which is great
for those who are on the go and need to
be connected
on the inside we have a 42 watt hour
battery
which is smaller than the macbook air 50
but the battery life is rated at a
massive
23 hours of video playback compared to
13 hours on the air
of course these numbers are usually
overrated compared to the real world
since brightness is usually turned down
as well as other things
but even if it is within the 18 hour
range it will be very impressive
and i do think that's possible since at
the heart of this machine we have the
snapdragon 8cx which is a 7 watt chip
the i5 on the air is a dual core model
where the 8cx is an 8 core
using four powerful cores and four power
efficiency cores
during the reveal of the hcx qualcomm
compared it to an 8th gen 1.6 gigahertz
quad core i5
that's available in many current windows
laptops and said that it was slightly
faster while using much less power
of course we will be doing a bunch of
tests when we get the galaxy book s in
by the way make sure to subscribe so you
guys don't miss out on that but at this
time there is very little performance
info on the cpu
and even less on the graphics we do have
some numbers from pc mark which
you guys can see right here and we also
found some tests for the macbook air
as you can see the acx is a fair ways
ahead realistically estimating the
performance in geekbench 4
it should get at least 12 000 in
multi-core compared to 7400 for the
macbook air
even though this laptop is fanless
throttling shouldn't be an issue like
the retina macbook was
due to the hcx's efficient 7 nanometer
design
on the graphics side we have the adreno
680 which is a more powerful version of
the 640 and the galaxy s10
and the note 10. and compared to the
intel uhd620 that's in that quad core i5
the adreno 680 is about 20 more powerful
meaning it should likely be at least 40
more powerful than the 617 in the
macbook air
and there'll be an even bigger
difference if you want to play some
light games
not only do we have great battery life
and respectable performance but the 8cx
packs in a ton of other things
into one chip we have the same amazing
x24 modem that's in the galaxy
s10 plus and note 10 which gave me much
better speeds and reception than my
iphone 10s
max and along with that we have the
latest wi-fi chips and bluetooth 5.
one big benefit of using an arm chip is
the built-in hardware designed for
specific tasks for example we have
native h.265
and vp9 decoding and encoding and it can
even handle up to 4k
120 frames per second another selling
point that is being marketed is the
galaxy book s being an always-on design
just like your phone
so you have to wait for it to start up
it should be instant as for memory we
have 256 gigabytes of storage which we
will test the speeds up when we get it
in
and eight gigabytes of new lp ddr4 ram
whereas apple is still using lp ddr3 but
that could be just an intel
restriction sound is another thing that
i'm curious to test out
samsung lists sound by akg which is a
brand that they own
and it's also labeled as dolby atmos
technology but we've seen those labels
on other machines where the speakers are
fairly weak whereas apple
always does a fantastic job with their
speakers now i mentioned
one disappointment with the system and
that is the display
it's a 1080p panel which makes sense
because they are focusing on battery
life
but what gets me is that it's labeled as
a tft display not an ips
i read through a bunch of hands-on
content and looked at some videos
and no one mentioned the display quality
for some weird reason
tft panels typically have worse color
accuracy and viewing angles
so that may be the biggest downside of
this ultralight machine
the brightness was also not mentioned so
that's something that we will be taking
a look at once we get it in
overall the galaxy book s looks like an
intriguing laptop with a nice ultra
light design and a usable amount of ram
and ssd in the base model
it starts at 9.99 compared to the 12.99
for a similar spec macbook air
but with more performance and battery
life of course a huge selling point for
macbook buyers is mac os
so if you need that no windows
alternative will steer you away but for
those open to windows
this may be a great option let us know
your thoughts on the galaxy book s
down below i would love to hear your
guys's opinions thanks for watching this
with max with max tech if you guys want
to see our full review along with
comparisons
make sure to hit that subscribe button
above and enable those notifications
down below
and if you're interested in seeing a
couple more videos you guys can check
them out
right over here i will see you guys in
the next video